amazon backs
marijuana legalization drops we testing
for some jobs it's a fox business story
amazon said on tuesday it supports a
proposed
u.s legislation to legalize cannabis at
the federal level and would stop
would drop we testing requirements for
some uh recruitments
amazon will also no longer screen as job
applicants for marijuana use for any
position not regulated by the department
of transportation
amazon's consumer boss dave clark said
while many u.s states have legalized
marijuana u.s employers
have so far largely refused to work with
the industry as cannabis is still
classified substance at the federal
level amazon was hit with a proposed
class action lawsuit
which claimed that the company was
violating a new york city law by testing
applicants for jobs
at local facilities for marijuana the
company does not allow marijuana
sales on its platform i think yet but i
think it will very soon time
you know this clearly speaks of one
thing bezos and lauren sanchez are
throwing some ragers
and he's getting high and it's a bad
look for the company if he's not pro
marijuana
divorce you know they have north of a
million employees you think they're
going to be able to continue to grow
if they're going to ban everybody that
smoke pot give me a break i mean that's
going to slow down their growth so they
had to do that
and plus we all know they're gearing up
for the pharmaceutical they're gonna i
think
what they do in pharmaceuticals is gonna
dwarf what they do with amazon prime
video
i mean this is just right for them to
destroy clearly there's a market in cbd
they're gonna be doing that
um and they're all in on getting it
legalized federally and if
amazon is behind it it's getting done
they didn't want a union in alabama it
didn't happen what they want they get
done over they're going to be selling it
within a year i think
selling it within a year some version of
it something we're going to see some
real legitimacy we'll see
cbd already on amazon absolutely i think
look again um what pisses me off and i
got to be honest it really does tick me
off
is we are going to be able to buy weed
that's delivered to you via a drone
before
we let people out of prison who are in
jail for selling
a leaf and that bothers me to no end it
bothers me to no end
that kamala harris in particular uh has
put i think pat you told me was 1400
people in jail for
for minor marijuana offenses and she has
the balls to own stock in marijuana
companies
can you imagine the balls on this woman
to put
people in jail for weed and then be a
part owner in a weed company
so look i think look this is a free
market thing i love it i think you
should be able to buy weed i think you
should be able to buy mushrooms i think
you should be able to buy lsd
whatever you want whatever consenting
adult wants to do in their free time
they should be allowed to do it and you
know what if mar
if i can have a drone deliver it to me
even better
even better man deliver me my cheetos my
weed
straight into my room i don't need to
leave i'm a happy camper okay
but i don't i cannot live in a society
where where my fat ass can be sitting on
a couch eating cheetos and smoking a
bowl while somebody is in jail for 30
years
for trying to provide me with that
happiness it's nonsensical
that we are still doing this put get let
these people out of jail tomorrow let
them out of jail today
if amazon is able to sell weed and you
have people in jail for selling weed
we have a a a morally corrupt society
i'm sorry that that's just
that to me is one of these things it's
just it it it's a wrong that we have to
write
be nice if they could yeah i did that i
did this last time i was on too i left
the room with an awkward silence i'm
sorry
let me tell a joke do you know anybody
in prison for selling weed i do okay
well or i would say i know people that
went to prison for selling weed and it
irrevocably changed their life for the
worse
we don't and that's the other thing
about not to get on a volume of weed
well yeah but i mean but weed is also
other things right like i mean you get
you do weed you do this you do that like
you know what whatever i mean when they
were rehabilitated
they were never anything but an ex-felon
either so it irrevocably changed their
their life for the worst and again we're
looking at it now that this is like a
fortune
a fortune five company is selling this
stuff you know but
but you know tom from the jersey shore
goes to jail and then you have
now even more if you want to talk about
a real guy russ albrick
russ ulbrick is going to spend the rest
of his life in jail for having the silk
road
which essentially was the dark web
amazon for drugs
and now amazon's going to sell drugs so
again we have a morally corrupt society
i'm sorry i think they're going to open
up
pharmacies yeah inside whole foods too i
i think they and dude i think they
should
look you're consenting adults and also
the whole idea of you have to drug test
your employees it says more about your
management
that they can't tell when their
employees are messed up that they have
to go drug test i remember being in the
minor leagues man i remember being in
the minor leagues and weed was illegal
but we could take as many percocets as
we want like toradol was fine we could
get a shot in our arm that made our body
go numb
and then you'd go play and now guys
would play and the pitchers
specifically they would turn their
bodies into chemistry sets that once
every five days they can go out
and throw 95 miles an hour tear
everything in their arm they wouldn't be
able to wash their hair after the game
it would take them three days to lift
their arm up
pop a couple perks and get back out
there and do it again
now you do that for five or six years
and then the team decides they don't
want you anymore hey thanks for your
service bud and they cut you
and now you got to go be a gym teacher
somewhere or or a gas station attendant
and you don't get to tell your body hey
i don't need 30 perks this week
and now they're they're addicted to
painkillers and the next thing you know
that that's
this is who their life is now i'm not
saying that weed is great and people
should i don't even smoke weed to be
honest with you i'm joking i don't even
smoke weed i don't like who i am on weed
i don't need anything to help me be fat
lazy and hungry i got that
covered okay so that i'm good at
came naturally this came with the gi joe
the kung fu grip with that
all right yeah but the shake what your
mama gave you but i'll tell you what
i tell you what when my body was hurting
my body was hurting and i was playing
ball you could give me some celebrex
and a percocet and i'd be zoom zoom and
then a perk would make me a little loopy
so i'd take an adderall to get back on
and i never once thought i was taking
drugs i thought i was playing the game i
thought i was doing what i had to do to
win
but that's a party yeah i got a
celebration of perkins saying in
addition
way more addictive than marijuana by the
way yeah and you know the sad thing is
nfl players that can't monitor or
you know regulate their pain imagine you
know with marijuana which would help
them did you know what we did we drank
ourselves to sleep
instead so all i'm saying is is that
this is an
antiquated model it's an antiquated
model a lot of it comes
from robber barons who owned
certain industries and use lobbying to
not have those industries be
be competed against both alcohol and
believe it or not timber there was a big
reason that marijuana was illegal in the
first place
is i i don't want to get this wrong but
i believe it was rockefeller owned
millions of acres of wood and hemp
actually
was a better source for pulp for paper
and he wanted hemp illegals so that they
had to use his wood for paper in all in
every school in america
instead of the hemp pulp somebody has to
look that up
you know but but yeah yeah i actually
you know you know one time i sat down
with oscar goodman i don't know if you
know oscar good morning
from mayor of vegas that was a great
time mayor of vegas and then his wife's
now been the two-time era vegas so for
the last 20 years
the goodmans have been running uh vegas
call saul
and he was in a movie casino he was in a
movie casino representing
you know when the whole thing was taking
place sharon stone all those guys were
at his house they were putting parties
together
and he told me he said i said so what do
you think about drugs he says anybody
wants to use it use it how about
prostitution do it it's your body how
about this
how about stealing nope if you're going
to steal from me we should cut your
thumb off that's it
he says yes because you're taking
something that's mine i think what is
happening
no harm what is happening naturally
libertarian philosophies are creating so
much momentum
naturally the only challenge is freedom
wins the only challenge is
there's never been a libertarian
candidate
worth promoting that knows how to
inspire and convert
mindset it's such a simple logical
concept to sell to people they've not
had a good crusader yet and hopefully
they'll find somebody that'll be able to
do it so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye